[Musique]
déjà présent chez plusieurs de nos
voisins le variant omicron n'a pas
encore été officiellement détecté en
france mais huit cas possibles sont en
cours d'examen par mesure de précaution
la france a décidé de suspendre ses vols
avec sept pays d'afrique australe même
décision en allemagne en italie ou au
royaume uni en espagne la mesure entre
en vigueur demain sans attendre les
pays-bas ré instaurer un couvre-feu à
partir de 17h treize passagers en
provenance d'afrique du sud ont été
testés positifs au nouveau variant une
mesure prise pour au moins trois
semaines certains pays opte pour des
mesures plus radicales comme israël le
japon ferme ses frontières à tous les
ressortissants étrangers
ma crainte c'est que un jour ce virus
connaissent une mutation qui lui
permettent de s'attaquer aux jeunes
enfants
et ce jour là
nos sociétés se trouveront dans un
danger extrême de déstabilisation il
faut dire que l'organisation mondiale de
la santé vient d'annoncer que le nouveau
variant présente un risque très élevé au
niveau mondial ce que nous voyons dans
les hôpitaux en afrique du sud et
rappelez vous que je suis à l'épicentre
puisque c'est là que je pratique ce que
nous voyons est extrêmement léger nous
n'avons eu personne moi le jour viendra
où c'est la vaccination obligatoire qui
s'imposera vous pensez qu'on est là donc
on y va en tout cas j'ai toujours pensé
ça depuis le début attention fausse joie
doit messe à corriger le tir dans un
communiqué il n'y a actuellement aucune
information suggérant que les symptômes
associés à omicron sont différents les
premières infections signalées
concernaient des étudiants des individus
plus jeunes qui ont tendance à avoir une
maladie plus bénigne un policier hors
service se promène avec sa compagne dans
ce centre commercial situé dans le 13ème
arrondissement de paris alors que le
couple s'enlace un groupe d'individus
les interpelle le ton monte l'un d'eux
bouscule le fonctionnaire qui par
réflexe écarte sa compagne pour la
protéger il reçoit ensuite un coup de
couteau au niveau du ventre il est
transporté à l'hôpital en urgence
absolue sonné il tombe sur le tarmac
il a survécu il a survécu les employés
de l'aéroport n'en reviennent pas peu de
clandestins survivre au voyage caché
dans ce tout petit espace dans le train
d'atterrissage de l'avion les
témoignages déterminant qui ont permis
avec l'exploitation des images de
vidéo-surveillance d'interpeller un
homme hier soir un mineur âgé de 16 ans
soupçonné d'être l'auteur du coup de
couteau a été interpellé à son domicile
situé à proximité du centre commercial
aux états unis depuis 1947 au moins 129
clandestins ont été retrouvés cachés
dans des avions commerciaux
29 seulement ont survécu eric zemmour
est à deux doigts oui bien oui oui
d'annoncer sa candidature dès son
déplacement à marseille ce week-end
environ je pense que la candidature à
peu précipitée ou la pré candidature un
peu précipité d'eric zemmour est en
train de tourner au fiasco on ne sait
pas encore si c'est un garçon ou si elle
s'appellera corinne alors
une petite préférence mais j'ai pu me
procurer et là vous allez être fier de
moi la première échographie ont
l'impression que plus on sorte en fait
fait le diagnostic du pays maintenant
alors qu'il va être et il veut se
représenter et qu'il ya des élections
dans quelques mois du futur bébé zemmour
la voici
et là il trouve un moyen de s'excuser
tout en n'excluant pas c'est pas un
geste qu'est-ce qu'il dit fort
inélégance injuste de racaille mais
voyez donc oui on en est réduit
s'il te dire on est loin du général de
gaulle les dealers recrute sur les
réseaux sociaux vous allez le voir sur
ces images il s'agit d'une offre
d'emploi plus vrai que nature d'outiller
au niveau salaire la vidéo promet je
cite de faire des sous moi je serais pas
étonné qu eric ciotti serait non
seulement second tour mais mais gagne
l'élection primaire se sait c'est
l'homme qui a l'air le plus sincère et
le plus cohérent et tout ce qu'il dit
depuis quatre ans viateur et vendeurs
qualités requises vive d'esprit est à
l'affût une nouvelle provocation de ces
dealers metz marseille